[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to another
installment of harry potter theory we're
back again taking another look at all
the things that you've probably never
noticed in the harry potter films we'll
also be looking at the books but those
will be a separate set of videos today
we're starting the final film in the
series the deathly hallows part two
as the culmination of a decade of law
this movie is filled with interesting
lore and trivia and it'll be a blast to
look through every scene with you
10. harry's last day and his children's
first day the final scene from the
deathly hallows part two shows us harry
potter's life as a father
at platform nine and three quarters of
king's cross station howie saw the
eldest two children off as they began
their full semester at hogwarts school
of witchcraft and wizardry and as
harry's youngest boy boards the train
you might have heard a familiar sound
just like harry's final day at hogwarts
when he boarded the hogwarts express for
summer break potter's middle child albus
was sent off with the sounds of john
williams orchestral song leaving
hogwarts
9. harry doesn't have the last word as
the main hero of every movie harry
potter was used to having the final word
in each film the most famous line i'm
not going home not really has been
etched into my mind for the past 20
years as one of the most iconic moments
in film history
but there have been more than enough
memorable quotes throughout the eight
movies each one though was uttered by
harry except for the last one
when talking to his son albus harry asks
the nervous child if he's ready to board
the train to hogwarts and his son simply
responds ready
from that moment the stories of the
wizarding world focused on the middle
potter child and his failure to save
cedric diggory from certain death
eight the original monsters returned the
final film in the harry potter series
was almost purely focused on the
conflict between harry potter and lord
voldemort but even though tom riddle
stole so much of the limelight there
were plenty of secondary antagonists and
villains to go around
during the battle of hogwarts many of
the classic monsters that made the
earliest potter movies so memorable
returned for a second go at our heroes
there was a troll just like the one that
was set loose within hogwarts during
harry's first year there were also giant
spiders like the ones that filled the
forbidden forest where rubius hagrid had
secretly hid his childhood pet aragog
the acromantula
and to round them out fenrir greyback
the werewolf that infected remus lupin
showed up as well
if you can remember back to the events
of the prisoner of azkaban you'll recall
that harry ron and hermione faced off
against lupin in werewolf form
7. shortest harry potter movie harry
potter films are famously long
since they have to cover all four
seasons of harry's life and the
tumultuous school years he endured
there's more than enough plots to go
around in fact even though i love these
films as much as the next potterhead i
can't wait for the day that they create
a show based on the novels i'd love
nothing more than to watch 15 to 20
hours of episodes for each year harry
was enrolled at hogwarts if you'd want
that too leave a comment down below
but that's besides the point it turns
out when it comes to film length harry
potter and the deathly hallows part 2 is
the shortest of the bunch at 2 hours and
10 minutes that's a good bit shorter
than the longest one the chamber of
secrets which ran 2 hours and 41 minutes
and deathly hallows part 2 is even
shorter than the general average which
was about 2 and a half hours
6. snape doesn't call harry by his last
name
when you think about professor severus
snape what does he call harry during
class with a grim sour face he usually
spits out an accusatory potter whenever
he's forced to talk to harry but in the
deathly hallows part 2 when facing his
own demise snape allowed his cold
exterior to crack
and he revealed the depth of his love
for harry and called him by his first
name
of course snape's love for the boy was a
bit more complex than the affection
dumbledore or hagrid boar snape's
connection to harry was based on
severus's own devotion to the boy's
mother lily
5. ron's knight makes an appearance
within the room of requirement one of
the oldest props from the harry potter
films popped back up for a final time
while facing off against malfoy and his
goons harry ron and hermione passed by
one of the giant chess pieces that they
used during the events of the
philosopher's stone
in that film the three friends were
forced to complete a labyrinth of
challenges in order to gain access to a
magical rock at the very end the
philosopher's stone one of these
challenges designed in part by professor
mcgonagall was a massive version of
wizard's chess but with one small change
in this version the loser faced deadly
consequences
despite receiving a few bruises harry
and his friends defeated the game
and eventually faced off against
voldemort in the labyrinths in the
chamber
and in the deathly hallows part two the
chess piece that ron had chosen the
knight can be seen as the heroes retreat
from a wall of fiend fire before those
coins were real at one point in the film
harry ron and hermione snuck into
gringotts bank to seek out a horcrux in
bellatrixtor strange's vault
among all the golden candelabras and
giant gem laden goblets
there is one particular prop that was
the most labor intensive to produce
golden galleons while simple cgi might
have been enough to do the trick the
filmmakers behind the deathly hallows
part 2
opted to use practical effects instead
this meant that they created 200 000
gold coins and that was just for
lestrange's vault
3. bellatrix's symbolism this one's a
bit subtler than most but if you have a
chance to watch the film again pay
attention to where bellatrix lestrange
stands
to demonstrate her importance to lord
voldemort the witch is always depicted
at his right side as in his right hand
man or woman in this case
since bellatrix was one of voldemort's
most loyal death eaters this makes sense
but considering the future of the
wizarding world bellatrix's position at
his right hand side takes another
meaning
unknown to anyone else the pair actually
had a secret romantic relationship at
least according to the cursed child and
bellatrix actually gave birth to
voldemort's only child a powerful witch
named delfini
perhaps voldemort was aware of her role
and it was far greater than being his
right-hand woman
as voldemort saw himself as a king of
sorts perhaps he considered bellatrix
his queen
2. hermione flies on a broom it might be
strange to ask but have you ever seen
hermione fly on a broom
throughout the films we've had a chance
to see harry's harrowing adventures
around the quidditch pitch
and even saw the order of the phoenix
take to flight over the cityscape of
london but what about hermione well it
turns out with so little time and so
much story to tell
previous films never actually got around
to showing hermione flying a broomstick
it wasn't until the deathly hallows part
two that hermione actually sawed through
the sky
number one tom felton's real girlfriend
played his wife
in the final scene from the deathly
hallows part 2 we took a several year
jump into the future and finally had a
chance to see how the boy who lived
spent the rest of his life thankfully
harry seemed to have earned all the
sacrifices that his friends and mentors
made
along with ginny weasley he'd raised a
wonderful family with three gifted
children but it wasn't just harry's
future we saw among the many faces at
king's cross station one of potter's
strangest allies appeared as well
draco malfoy now a father brought his
son to the station to see him off to
school
draco was joined by his wife astoria
malfoy we didn't know it at the time but
in the years to come astoria's life
would take a tragic turn
a blood curse would end her life leaving
her children without a mother and adding
even more tragedy to draco's turbulent
life
but if you paid close attention to actor
tom felton's personal life then you
might have known that astoria wasn't
portrayed by any old actress
no felton's real girlfriend at the time
a stunt coordinator named jade olivia
assumed the role and there you have it
10 things you might have missed from the
deathly hallows part 2. if you have any
facts or tidbits of your own make sure
you share them in the comments below
stay tuned for more videos like this
from the other films as well as a series
focusing on things you missed in the
books if you enjoy the content please
like the video and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember there
is plenty to be learned even from a bad
teacher what not to do how not to be
[Music]
[Music]
you